OK, Donald Trump has started the pardons while
he's continuing the pardons speculation for
several weeks about exactly when a flurry
of pardons and commutations would come from
Donald Trump.
Speculation continues about the preemptive
pardons Trump is said to be considering for
Rudy Giuliani and his children, his son in
law, Jared Kushner, and many, many others.
But there are now 15 or so more pardons and
commutations issued yesterday by Donald Trump.
Now, as far as the Russia probe, remember
the one that led to all sorts of arrests and
indictments?
Donald Trump has pardoned his own former foreign
policy adviser, George Papadopoulos, who was
found guilty of lying to federal investigators,
as well as Alex Vanders, one who was the Dutch
lawyer who also lied to investigators in connection
with the Russia investigation.
So slowly but surely, Donald Trump is pardoning
everybody who is wrapped up in the Mueller
probe is a sort of revisionist history.
The investigation did find lots of crimes.
They like to claim it didn't.
But in any case, Trump will just keep pardoning
everybody and in a way retroactively wipe
the slate clean.
Even those folks were convicted.
And a pardon part of, you know, this is a
kind of a bigger legal debate.
But if you're pardoned, then you're conceding
you were guilty.
Now, you could say, well, it was an unfair
guilty verdict and you can make that case.
Donald Trump also pardoning former Republican
Congressman Duncan Hunter, former Republican
Congressman Chris Collins for Blackwater mercenaries
involved in an Iraqi massacre.
That's an entire other story.
We previously covered two Border Patrol agents
convicted in 2006 for shooting and wounding
an unarmed undocumented immigrant and then
actually covering it up.
Just a horrible signal that that sends Trump
pardoned several people convicted of nonviolent
drug crimes who were serving long sentences
that I agree with.
Trump also pardoning Alfonso Costa, a dentist
who pleaded guilty to health care fraud, Alfred
Lee Crum, who pleaded guilty to illegally
distilling moonshine 70 years ago.
Weldon Angelos, who was sentenced to 55 years
for selling marijuana and carrying a handgun.
Philip Limón, County commissioner in Utah,
who was sentenced to 10 days in jail because
of his protest on ATV restrictions on federal
land.
OK, and Otis Gordon, who was convicted of
possession with intent to distribute.
Also Philip Formas, a Florida nursing home
mogul convicted for paying bribes in a Medicare
fraud case, also had some of his sentence
commuted by Trump.
And in addition to the pardons, a number of
commutations, the remaining prison term of
former Congressman Steve Stockman.
That's the Texas Republican convicted for
almost two dozen felonies, including fraud
and money laundering.
And Trump saying that because Stockman is
64 with underlying preexisting conditions,
he's at greater risk during covid and he already
got covid while in prison.
What's interesting about that is Trump says,
hey, I'm good now because I got covid.
But even though this guy already got covid
and recovered, it's still a reason to pull
him from prison.
A little bit incoherent, but it is Trump after
all.
So the big picture here is, number one, this
is likely to be just the start of Donald Trump's
pardons.
Number two, this is a separate path to separate
topic than the preemptive pardons being considered
for his family members, people like Jared
Kushner, Ivanka Don Jr., Eric Trump.
And we've learned over the last seven to 10
days the possible reasons they would benefit
from a preemptive pardon.
Jared Kushner potentially already being investigated
for creating this shell company through which
hundreds of millions of dollars in campaign
donations may have been laundered.
Rudy Giuliani reportedly talking to Trump
about a preemptive pardon, etc..
But here is the clear trend.
And actually listen to this data point.
Harvard Law School Professor Jack Goldsmith
looked at Trump's pardons so far and found
that 88 percent of the pardon so far are for
people either.
Personally tied to Trump or people whose actions
furthered Trump's political aims or protected
him in some way, now presidents have absolute
pardon power.
We know that Trump has repeated that often.
It's not really in question.
Legally speaking.
The issue here is that it's always more corrupt
with Trump.
So many of the pardons are for crimes committed
by people connected to Trump or even people
who helped Trump by the crimes they committed,
including lying to investigators ostensibly
to protect Donald Trump in the Mueller probe.
So we can have a broader debate about pardons
in general.
And we've had that debate, and that's not
really the topic here with Trump.
There's always he's able to dial up the corruption
and cronyism just a little bit or even significantly.
And that's exactly what he's done here.
And we'll wait and see what the full list
of pardons as